sergey karjakin was originally a
qualifier for the candidate tournament
but was disqualified
for breaching the fide code of ethics
after publicly expressing approval for
the
2022 russian invasion ukraine when you
look at the cold war and some of the us
versus russian games of the past does
politics
the some of this geopolitics politics
ever
creep its way into the game do you feel
the pressure the immensity of that as it
does sometimes for the olympics you know
these big nations playing each other
competing against each other almost like
fighting out
you know in a friendly way
the battles the tensions that they have
in the space of geopolitics
yeah i think it still does
so the president of the world chess
federation who was just reelected is is
is a russian like i like him personally
uh for sure
but he is quite connected to the kremlin
like and it's
quite clear that the kremlin considers
it at least a semi-important goal to
bring the chess crown home to to russia
so it's still it's still definitely a a
factor and i mean i can answer for in
the karjakin case like i don't have a
strong
opinion on on whether
he should have been banned or not
obviously i don't agree with anything
that he
he says
but
in principle i think
that you should
ban either no russians or all russians
i'm generally
not
particularly against either but
i don't
love
banning wrong opinions even if they are
as reprehensible as assists have been
yeah there's something about
the world chess championships or the
olympics
where it feels like banning is
counterproductive to the alleviating
some of the conflicts
we don't know this is the thing though
yeah we really don't know about the the
long-term
conflicts and a lot of people try to do
the right the right thing in this sense
which i don't really blame at all it's
just that
it's just that we don't know and
i guess sometimes
there are other ways you want to try and
try to help us well
see like within the competition within
some of those battles of us versus
russia or so on of the past there's also
between the individuals
um maybe you'll disagree with us but
from a spectator perspective there's
still a camaraderie
like at the end of the day there's a
thing that unites you which which is
this like appreciation
of the fight over the chessboard
it's um even if you hate each other yeah
for sure i think for
every every match that spin
you would briefly discuss the game with
your opponent after
after the game no matter how much you
hate each other and i i think that's
lovely and kasparov i mean he was quoted
like one somebody in his team asked him
like why why are you talking to
the carp of after the game like he
you hate that guy and he's like yeah
sure but he's the only one who
understands me yeah the only one who
understands so that's uh no i think
that's really lovely and i would love to
see that in other
in other areas was as well that you can
regardless of what happens you can have
you can have a good chat about the game
you can you can just talk about
the ideas with people who who understand
what you what you understand
you